I think when people see a Carnival, they don't realize how much work goes behind it.
People are working all year long on every Carnival season...
...and one of the hardest working people of Carnival are the costume makers.
This is really the tip of the iceberg.
We have 25,000 costumes, uniforms and dresses in our collection.
So this is just a very, very small piece...
...of the Louisiana State Museum Carnival and textile and costume collection.
What we try to show is that Carnival is really an art form,...
...and it's almost like grand opera in that it combines music and costumes...
...and set design and all kinds of different kind of theatrics.
And that's what visitors to the museum will see.
They'll see another side of Carnival, they'll see it going all the way back to the 1700s.
They'll see all of the artistry that goes into the Carnival celebration.
There's nothing like this museum, I don't think, on the planet,...
...just like there's nothing like Carnival.